وشهدت صور فيديو لاستهداف احدى هذه
العربات واذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي تعترف
باصابه جندي اسرائيلي في هذه العمليه
سميره تفاصيل معك
نعم زين العابدين يعني هذا المجموعات
عارين الاسود هي دائما تقول بانها مستعده
لاي عمليه اقتحام اسرائيليه
لمدينه نابلس واليوم كان هناك حسب بيان
مجموعات عارين الاسود التي تحدث بانها
تمكنت من تفجير عضوه ناسفه شديده الانفجار
في احدى القوات الخاصه الاسرائيليه عند
عبور واقتحام اليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
الى احدى احد احياء البلده القديمه في
مدينه نابلس وقد تم تفجير هذه العبوه عن
بعد مما ادى الى وقوع اصابات بليغه بين
صفوف الجيش الاصلي حسب بيان مجموعات عرين
الاسود والذين اكدت ايضا في بيانها بان
مقاتليها وجندها قد تمكنوا من عمليه مع
بقيه الفصائل الفلسطينيه المسلحه من تشكيل
حزام ناري للقوات الاسرائيليه من ثلاث
محاور عند الاقتحام وقد كان هناك عمليات
اشتباك مسلحه مع قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي تحدثت
وقالت بان احد الجنود الاسرائيليين قد
اصيب بجروح وصفت بيئه الطفيفه خلال تفجير
هذه العبوه الناسفه خلال نشاطها العسكري
صباح هذا اليوم في داخل حياية القريون
والمخفيه في داخل البلده القديمه من مدينه
نابلس والتي كانت تستهدف خلالها هذه
العمليه العسكريه التي استغرقت نحو ساعه
من الزمن اعتقال اثنين من المطلوبين لدى
سلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه عندما حاصرت
منزلين في حي القريون وايضا حي المخفيه
وقد تم اعتقال المشتبهين والمطلوبين لدى
قوات الاحتلال الاسبانيه ونقلتهما بعد
انسحابهم الى اجهزه الامن الايطاليه
للتحقيق معهم في قضايا تتعلق بعمليات
اطلاق نار وايضا قضايا تتعلق بمقاومه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ايضا مجموعات عرين
الاسود انتهزت هذه هذا التصعيد ايضا في
قطاع غزه واكدت بانها لا يعلو صوت فوق صوت
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وايضا لا يعلو صوت
فوق صوت المعركه واكدت بانها على اتم
الاستعداد
للمناصره ومؤازره المقاومه الفلسطينيه في
ردها على العدوان والتصعيد الاسرائيلي
الذي استهدف قطاع غزه هذا فجر هذا اليوم
الذي ادى الى سقوط المزيد من الشهداء
والجرحى بينهم الكثير من المدنيين
الفلسطينيين على
المستوى الميداني الامني ايضا كان هناك
بيانين منفصلين لشرطه الاحتلال وقوات
الاحتلال تحدث عن ان هناك عمليات احباط
لمحاولات عم تنفيذ عمليه طعن في داخل
البلده القديمه في مدينه القدس المحتله
وايضا في ابي القرب من مستوطنهار جنوبي
مدينه نابلس حيث تم
احباطين المحاولتين واعتقال بين بعد ان تم
الاشتباه بهما والعثور على الات حاده
بحوزتهما ايضا على مستوى ردود الفعل
الرسميه الفلسطينيه كان هناك المتحدث باسم
الرئاسه الفلسطينيه قد ادانا هذا التصعيد
الخطير في قطاع غزه والضفه الغربيه بما في
ذلك القدس المحتله وايضا استهداف الاطفال
والنساء وسقوط هذا العدد من الشهداء
والجرحى في هذا العدوان وهذا التصعيد
الاسرائيلي وحملت الحكومه الاسرائيليه
تداعيات ونتائج مثل هذا التصعيد
الاسرائيلي الذي يجر المنطقه الى المزيد
من الدوامه العنف والتوتر وايضا عدم
الاستقرار وايضا حذرت الاداره الامريكيه
من عدم السماح او السماح للقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه وسلطات الاحتلال بالتمادي
اكثر في جرائمها بحق الفلسطينيين
وممتلكاتهم وارواحهم وايضا كان هناك
الرئيس الوزراء الفلسطيني قد ادان هذا
التصعيد واعتبر ان هذا العدوان على قطاع
غزال هو بمثابه ارهاب دوله منظم وايضا
محاوله لتصدير الازمات الداخليه في داخل
اسرائيل وايضا هي ترجمه لعمليه وحقيقيه
لعمليات الحرق والاباده الجماعيه التي
يجاهد ويتفاخر بها حكام اسرائيل ضد
الفلسطينيين شكرا جزيلا لك من رام الله
سمير ابو شماله مراسله الجزيره